Come on rick we're almost there uh leave me morty
it's the only way what were we are we blades in
that one that's tight Welcome back everyone this
is going to be my new rick and morty season 5
episode 1 video rick and morty is finally back
i'll be doing videos for all the episodes in
season five we have ten episodes total coming with
no breaks that's right they're not breaking the
season in half like they did during season four
so be sure to subscribe to get everything also
do a rick and morty merch giveaway all you have to
do to enter that is be a subscriber and just leave
all your favorite easter eggs from the episode
on the video careful for spoilers if you have
not seen the episode yet we'll talk about easter
eggs and moments throughout the episode and i'll
just number these as we go along shot by shot just
to stay organized the writer of the episode jeff
lubness said that he was inspired by a lot of
90s x-men that he baked into the episode which
is where a lot of the mr nimbus namor jokes come
from he's based on marvel's name or but the same
way that a former rick and morty writer is now the
showrunner on the loki marvel series the writer of
this particular episode of rick and morty season 5
episode 1 is also the person who's writing ant-man
3 quantumania which the loki series also being
written by a rick and morty person is also going
to cross over or help set up ant-man 3 quantumania
with king the conqueror so there's a whole lot of
weird marvel crossover energy happening with rick
and morty right now whether it's on purpose or by
coincidence dan harmon was telling jokes about
how marvel keeps stealing all the writers from
his show then we have the brand new season 5 intro
scene and obviously the trick is always to spot
which of these scenes are from actual episodes
and which of them are supposed to be fake although
the joke is is they might be from future episodes
they just haven't done yet but it starts with all
their heads sprouting legs and climbing off their
bodies don't know if that's from an actual episode
some are smashing mailboxes but the mailboxes are
alive and it's a mailbox based planet that's from
an actual episode because it appears in the
season 5 trailer the voltron rick and morty
is from an actual episode there's rick trying to
give cpr to noob noob from the vindicators i don't
know this is from an actual episode but they are
doing a full-blown rick and morty spin-off series
just for the vindicators no idea when those
episodes are airing though then the last new
scene is morty as a golf champion and like that's
the only weird thing that's going on in the scene
nothing else crazy is happening so not sure if
that's from an actual episode yet let me know
in the comments which scenes of these you think
will not appear in episodes the actual title of
the episode was morty dinner rick andre which is
a reference to my dinner with andre this really
cool classic indie movie about a conversation the
two friends have over dinner the main character
andre is this former director lamenting that his
life hasn't been as successful as he wanted and
he's kind of fallen on hard times in wallace shaw
his friend in the movie spends their conversation
trying to convince him otherwise like they have
this long history together which is also a bit
of a reference to mr nimbus and rick's backstory
during the episode which itself was another kind
of joke about comic book tropes introducing a new
character that has all this crazy pre-existing
backstory with all the main characters but that
you as an audience member or a comic book reader
are just meeting on the page right here like wait
a minute where's this character been this whole
time why are they only just mentioning him now if
he's supposed to be so important rick also calls
that out later in the episode when he says don't
go trying to establish canonical backstory with
me when mr nimbus tries to explain what was going
on with rick's wife diane they actually said they
created the mr nimbus character for an episode a
long time ago but then wound up not using him so
he just sat on a shelf metaphorically and they
decided to bring him back and turn it into this
episode but they started the episode with this big
cold open that they actually posted the animatic
of years ago at comic con but it's them escaping
the events of this previous adventure that they've
been on amidst all these time crystals these
different shards throwing them different realities
is like a slightly different twist on the idea of
the time crystals from season four episode 1 which
also was consequently a pretty big jessica episode
but if you zoom in enhance you can actually spot
what most of these are some of them are a little
too small and blurry but there's a morty cradling
a baby rig there's one with them both holding each
other cowering like they're about to die one where
rick has a giant beam cannon weapon then a cool
morty like the fawns with a leather jacket and
shades there's a lego rick and morty there's one
over here that seems like men in black versions
of rick and morty with the suits and the shades on
i can't read the text in this one on the ad behind
these two as they're walking by it but they're
walking past some advertisement on the wall here
there's a lumberjack rick here that's getting
ready to chop down a morty tree and another one up
here with both of them in awe of something that's
happening outside the ship there's one with rick
all cranked out like his head is about to explode
or he's been taken over by some virus or parasite
then the very obvious blade rick and morty
reference from the first blade movie inside
that club notice here too that the vampires are
designed like the other canonical vampires like
standard rick and morty vampires from way back
in season two they were also recently running
a new wendy's ad where rick says that morty
is impressive for having befriended dracula
and then betrayed him but the ads like those are
supposed to be non-canonical there's another one
with a revolutionary war rick and morty either
they broke their no time travel rule again
on the show like they did during the snake jazz
episode or this is cosplay then there's a bird
version of rick and morty there's also another
one of them falling through the air and this is
actually a pretty cool one because some of you
may have referenced that it's actually a scene
so i think the idea is that some of these smaller
alternate reality clips where it just seems like
normal things are happening or actually taken
from previous episodes is that they're trying
to acknowledge that fan theory that a lot of times
maybe in different episodes we follow completely
different versions of the characters and they just
don't tell you like it's not always c137 rick in
his current version of morty here that's been a
fan theory for many many years now that they've
never really acknowledged there's a very hip-hop
looking version of rick and morty like they both
have tons of gold chains and bling on them like
they're mr t this one actually looks like they're
kind of naked and in the front yard of the house
from the simpsons there was a simpsons crossover
but they did it for an intro scene some of these
other ones in the background here just a little
too small and blurry to make out what's happening
they just barely make it through the portal back
to earth then as the ship starts crashing to
earth like morty is pretty convinced that they're
going to die on impact because he can't get the
controls to work he calls jessica as his last act
he's finally going to be honest with jessica about
his feelings and she actually almost sounds like
she's ready to reciprocate potentially there might
be potential for a relationship so in classic
morty fashion he cramers his way into landing
the spaceship in the ocean and they used this to
introduce mr nimbus in the episode like the writer
said the joke of the episode was there's one name
that rick fears and that name is nimbus like i
said it's meant to be that comic book trope joke
of introducing the character that's supposed to be
super important but you've only met them just now
it'd be like if you never heard of thanos or the
infinity stones until the first five seconds of
infinity war like wait a minute why is he supposed
to be so powerful and important i don't understand
then as rick is setting the table back at home
everybody sort of comments on this like wait a
minute have you ever heard about this nimbus
person no have you heard about this person
morty tries to bail on helping him because jessica
is coming over so rick has gone to summer now
which he has frequently done in the past couple of
seasons to replace morty as sort of the psychic on
episodes and she goes to steal his forbidden shell
that gives him his power in the marianas trench
i love the way they write a lot of the extra
backstory for a lot of these side characters too
especially what was going on with the whole narnia
realm like all the stuff in the narnia realm
could be its own tv series like they could do a
full-blown spin-off with the amount of stuff that
they did during that the funny thing you notice
here too is they're still preparing the dinner
is that rick has like a whole special chair for
mr nimbus that it looks like he keeps in storage
like he pulls it out every time he's come over in
the past and when mr nimbus comes over he makes
it sound like he used to visit rick all the time
like he knows all these things about rick that a
lot of the other family members don't know like
revealing that rick had a sidekick before morty
that was named kyle and morty's like hey wait a
minute what the reason why rick doesn't want to
talk about it during the episode is more of a meta
thing from the writers like the writers don't want
to completely explain his character ever that's
why he gets really upset about creating canonical
backstory later when he starts talking about his
wife dan and justin have basically said that they
never plan on fully explaining everything about
rick's backstory as long as the show is still
running and for whatever reason this week on rick
and morty everybody on the show is horny on main
then proceeds to try and shame beth and jerry
for not getting any setting up their whole
horny arc with them trying to do the weird stuff
as part of their couple's therapy with dr wong
and they're actually bringing dr wong back to the
show like susan sarandon is going to come back for
future episodes so they said that beth and jerry's
whole arc this season at least for most of season
five will be about them experimenting with couples
therapy doing all kinds of weird different stuff
which is how they get to the whole threesome
stuff with nimbus like apparently dr wong is
encouraging them to go full-blown degenerates with
their graphic nintendo videos and sleeping around
it's meant to be funny and super gross at the
same time like nobody nobody wants to hear about
their parents lives we also find that rick puts
suicide capsules in all of beth and jerry's teeth
and then rick sets up that whole subplot with
the wine in the narnia culture the premise being
that mr nimbus only drinks really good wine so
they have this really cheap stuff that they're
going to throw into an altered dimension with
time dilation so that ages to good wine by the
time nimbus arrives they use it for that sick
chronicles of narnia burn when rick says that
he's not a beaver that believes in jesus christ
that's a reference to the extremely religious
overtones written into the chronicles of narnia
if you haven't reread those books as an adult like
obviously they're mostly written for children but
you reread them as an adult you kind of pick up on
a lot of the religious themes you could take that
as a good thing or a bad thing depending on how
you feel about religion but then morty complains
about how dumb he is and he's not wrong because
rick does keep pulling him out of school for
adventures and they don't stop time for those
like time keeps moving normally inside the regular
universe while they're away they actually called
this out back during season 1 with the whole
scary terry episode when rick calls mr nimbus
an ice cold dick killer that's also meant to be a
reference to how mr nimbus has sex with everything
that moves he rolls up on that giant sea creature
chariot on a magical wave they kind of explain his
powers in the episode he's meant to be hilariously
op but he's basically an amalgam of marvel's namor
with the same powers and a couple of extra ones
thrown on top just for comedic value like he
apparently also has broad-based telepathic powers
because he can force the police to fight then have
sex with each other on the lawn right in front of
them he controls the water all sea creatures of
course and he's powerful enough politically and
socially that he controls the human police too
he's emperor of the oceans and he controls the
police the part about the police mostly felt like
it was there in service of the payoff at the
end of the episode where he has rick arrested
they sort of set the tone for the episode too for
the character when he just starts making every
possible sexual innuendo and metaphor at jerry
and beth and rubbing his junk all over everyone
anytime he talks to them jerry also references
rick doing it with a planet that's a reference
to season four's chilled rick of mort episode
where he admitted to doing it with the planet
it's sort of setting up the idea that he also
slept with mr nimbus at one point which they pay
off at the end of the episode where he's like oh
yes rick would understand mr nimbus also says that
none of the other family members know rick the
way that he does like in the biblical sense but i
love how nonchalant jessica is about all this when
she walks up like all the mr nimbus stuff is going
on in the front yard like she rolls up as the
police are doing it with each other in the front
lawn there's all these ocean creatures flopping
around and she treats it like it's no big deal
she's just here for some wine i also love the idea
that mr nimbus has threesomes so frequently that
he standardized the process and he has like this
little sidekick there that rolls up with all the
forms like please read these sign here and make
sure to put your address so we know where to send
the gift basket afterwards then one of the bigger
surprises in the episode was morty almost turns
the episode itself into another inner dimensional
cable episode when they're sitting down trying to
find out what to watch like do you want to watch
some interdimensional cable then when morty turns
the tv on it's a parody of nintendo 64 called
nintendo 69 and even though they had the lead
in with beth and jerry talking about watching a
bunch of adult videos together rick actually kind
of gives away that the tape belonged to him when
he's shouting at mr nimbus about how he's been 69
nintendo's all over the place this is like the
horniest episode of rick and morty ever i love
their attention to detail here too like they have
the original nes model looking nintendo like it's
a alive anthropomorphized wearing a thong and the
controllers flapping around jessica kind of makes
it seem like she's dtf if morty can just give her
some of that sweet wine he does wind up getting a
kiss out of her later so we'll call that a big w
for morty in the episode in just a long line of
l's morty takes the l more than any other
character on the show when he goes back to
steal the wine you meet the hoovy character he's
actually played by jim gaffigan so he's like their
celebrity cameo during the episode and they said
the whole twist of this morty arc within creating
enemies in this other culture was in service of
rick's comments about how life is a fight and no
matter how well intentioned you are you always are
going to make enemies it doesn't matter how nice
you are but the whole idea of this time dilation
in this alternate culture war is a very familiar
sci-fi trope they even already used the idea on
rick and morty during season two and the ricks
must be crazy with the whole microverse miniverse
in the teeny verse like even in that episode they
also had another nemesis of rick's zeb zanflorp
rick and morty has just been going on long enough
as a show that enough episodes that they started
to reference themselves over and over again just
like the simpsons just like south park like all
long-running shows do then huvi goes back and they
start paying off the time dilation joke and it
turns into like darkest timeline even though morty
keeps trying to avoid trouble and just go for the
wine he keeps inadvertently hurting or killing
different generations of the family until it
escalates into this big religious thing like they
create this whole religion around hating morty
as sort of this demonic figure to their people
when hoovie goes back into his house and finds the
bones of his wife there and his son's gone crazy
that's meant to be a direct reference to alfred
hitchcock's psycho where norman bates has been
keeping the bones of his mother in the basement
and as they keep jumping back and forth between
the storylines you find out that summer has been
slaughtering nimbus people something fierce like
she's actually probably the most successful
character in the episode she totally got the
horn like she's a stone cold killer pro they also
reveal that rick craps in the ocean on the regular
just to spite mr nimbus then when morty goes back
to get more wine and makes the reference to old
people always being so buff that's another season
4 callback to the really buff train conductor
played by paul giamatti they also had a lot of
those references in that episode too jokes about
really old ripped guys they do the huge montage
of the evolution of their culture across the years
and now they're in medieval level technology
back in the kitchen though beth and jerry
learned that they might die by snooze new that's
another futurama joke death by sex basically
rick directly calls out the frasier tv show trope
of whispering in the kitchen during a dinner
party then when morty fails to get more wine then
returns to get some of rick's weapons to help him
in the time that it takes him to do that they have
this giant subplot that spans across many years
that goes full game of thrones where the king's
son is banished for not believing that morty is
real the king's advisor is this evil mage trying
to usurp the throne by lying about morty training
the prince to kill his father one day performing
all these occult rituals on him all these magical
pages that are floating around him are just meant
to depict what happened each time morty came
through the portal and i love how far down this
story rabbit hole the episode goes for this side
plot they do it again later in the episode too and
then pull the rug out from all these characters
right after they go full red wedding on the king
in the rest of the family year like morty portals
in and the evil mage is like holy crap i was so
wrong about all this the whole time they said at
the next big narnia montage when he leaves behind
rick's hypertech gauntlet in some of his dna morty
finally gets that kiss from jessica so call that
a win then they have that next big future montage
it's very similar to the last one where you have
like a mother training her son in the future to
travel back through a portal of their own making
to go kill morty the writer of the episode
also said that it was about the way we fail our
mothers and even though he was kind of joking in
that comment i think he was referencing this whole
twist with this character here the atom character
like he failed his mother's mission to kill morty
like when he sees the time owl at the end of time
and says mother don't worry i'll explain the time
alone in a second the writers were talking about
that it was actually pretty hilarious i did kind
of laugh at how crazy hardcore this got like it's
meant to be so over the top like they melt down
other members of their race into liquid so that it
turns into breathable material for him inside the
suit when he enters the portal the whole joke with
the warrior stopping dead in his tracks at the
sight of mr nimbus though questioning who the hell
is this guy is just meant to be another callback
to that whole trope of introducing the super op
comic book character that you've never met till
now like wait a minute who's this guy why is he
so important and just a follow-up on the idea of
how hilarious this all is how much they're calling
these tropes out jessica the most unassuming side
character in the episode is the one to actually
kill him that's also meant to be set up for her
big speech at the end of the episode too about
how she realizes that she's a side character in
a television show but this whole sequence here
with the alien traveling to the end of time this
cosmic owl that was supposed to be kind of like
the cosmic owl from adventure time just existing
here at the end of time for this one-off gag but
he's canon to the rick and morty multiverse now so
he actually does exist here the character design
also kind of reminded me of the super scary owl
from the rats of nim animated movie if you haven't
seen that it's just a totally terrifying movie
let me know if that gave you nightmares when you
were a little kid then when morty goes back to get
wine for the final time their culture has gotten
so advanced and evolved into this cybernetic race
almost like full-blown transformers so it's like
they've been able to shed their physical bodies
at this point and just exist as machines and they
kind of turn it into a star trek transformers
beast war parody they do this big holodeck
simulation to trick morty and they're just calling
this guy gardener morty who funny enough even
though this is all supposed to be a trick of the
mind the lesson that he imparts on regular morty
here about how he's got to learn to move past his
obsession with jessica is completely correct and
accurate to the plot of the rest of the episode
the way they pay it off at the end like jessica
reveals that she was conscious the whole time
and kind of evolved into this higher state of
being this cosmic awareness like she jokes about
being a time god which may or may not be true but
she tells morty that it's never going to happen we
should just be friends even though they will try
again several times like she's seen their future
and they will try again a couple times that's
also a bit of the writers joking about how they're
going to continue to do morty and jessica episodes
in the future even though ultimately morty might
never actually get with jessica which is very much
in the character of morty like the whole idea that
he's completely obsessed with this one thing but
never ever winds up getting it but gets close a
couple times like he did get that kiss then they
pay off a huge easter egg when they confirm that
mr nimbus rules over the same version of atlantis
from the events of the ricklantis mix-up back
in season 3 episode 7. that was the tales from
the citadel episode during that they had the big
fake out intro where he and morty actually go to
atlantis to get a ton of mermaid tank and during
their fight here rick mentions that saying that he
d-dayed a ton of mermaid poon they revealed that
that race kept jessica frozen in the time crystal
all that time the cyborg cloned himself genitals
for some reason too that all the buildings start
turning into transformers chasing after them so
when rick has that big cyberpunk bird call out
that's a beast wars reference they reveal that
their tech is more advanced than rick's but it's
mostly set up for the joke about mr nimbus being
so op like he's more powerful than rick rick's
afraid of him and he has to save them when jessica
goes into her huge monologue about how she's this
time god she talks about how she's only a side
character in a story that's a meta joke about her
literally being a side character on the rick and
morty tv show like she's only existed for morty
jokes and now she wants more for herself so it's
almost like her gaining more cosmic awareness like
rick knows that he's a character in a tv show
she kind of knows that she's inside a tv show
now the way they play it she may or may not be a
time god now like when she yells at the dude who
propositions her as she's walking by his car
like shut up i'm a time god now it's meant to
be kind of ambiguous like jessica probably is
not a time god we'll see if they ever wind up
continuing that storyline or calling back to it
in some future joke then the actual post-credits
scene is then paying off the threesome joke like
mr nimbus has his own dumpy looking apartment
cheap looking apartment that he keeps just for
stuff like this and like i said when he says
that rick would understand he's implying that
rick also had threesomes with him in the past
but if you spotted any other easter eggs in the
episode that i didn't mention during the video
just write down below in the comments there were
a ton of references but it was the first episode
of the season and those episodes tend to be a
little bit bigger i will do an episode 2 trailer
video tomorrow at some point so make sure you
have alerts enabled for my channel so you don't
miss any of that like i said the former rick and
morty writers working on the loki series my loki
episode 3 video will also post on wednesday just
like normal everyone click here for my full loki
episode 2 video and click here to learn how the
loki series just set up spider-man no way home in
doctor strange too thank you so much for watching
everyone stay safe and i'll see you guys tonight!